There's a tendency to look down on tablature
at least by classical guitarists they think
of it as two simple crude so in this video I
like to debunk that idea by showing you that
tablature was actually the dominant style of the
notation for plucked instruments like the lute,
guitar, theorbo and more for more than 400 years
so the next part of this video I'm going to
explain what we can learn about performance
practice the composer's intent and much more from
looking at these historical documents when we
learned to read from historical tablature which
by the way is very easy I have to emphasize you
can do this I promise when you learn to read it
and start looking at all this free digital content
available online like websites like imslp.org
you'll find countless examples books and books
of tablature and in that tablature one of the
things you'll notice is there's lots and lots
of symbols on the page symbols like a sharp
sign or a little squiggle or a comma this is
how Renaissance and baroque composers notated
ornaments that is to say things like trills
importance and much more often these composers
will tell us what their symbols mean at the
beginning of each book and what you'll see is
they ornamented a lot more than we think they
did for example let's take a peek at this famous
piece by John Dowland called the Frog galliard
each measure that's telling us to
do some type of ornament. Trill,
appogiatura or mordent. so if I only played the
notes on the page I would get something like this
and of course that sounds nice but when
you actually understand what the symbols
mean the music is much more elaborate
and freely with all sorts of beautiful
decorations on top the first chord isn't
just but it's with the trill on the top
note people at the time write about the idea
that they thought ornamentation added Grace
and charm to their music with another one in
the second measure and then the third measure
two in the third measure actually another one
here another one and again another one yeah
the next thing we can learn from historical
tablature is especially in the Baroque Period
they used lots and lots of slurs I'm not holding a
baroque Guitar by the way you can learn all about
this in the video in the description slurs
are things like hammer-ons and pull-offs so
you pluck one note in the right hand and then
you hit in the left hand hard enough to make
a pitch that's a hammer on and if you pluck a
note in the right hand and you pluck the string
with your left hand only that's called a pull-off
Baroque music is so full of these types of slurs
[Music] [Music] these long swooping
lines tell us to only pluck once and then
do the rest in our left hand
so knowing this brings us closer to the
performers at the time it shows us what
they wanted musically because if they didn't
write that slur and they wanted me to play
that sounds very heavy but what they're telling us
by putting this big swooping line over many notes
is they want it to be more elegant
they're more Legato connected and
smooth we can see a great example
of slurs being used for a very
important musical reason in this menu
or minuet by Robert de Visée [Music]
in the B section of this dance we see the
following in slow motion three notes in a slur
a long Trill which is slurred trails
in the baroque period are slurred on
guitars and lutes not done cross-string like
some Modern players do today which makes it
rather well let's call it a non-baroque
sound then in the third measure of the
B section we actually get five notes in a
row that are played only with the left hand
have a pluck and then several light
graceful notes which is very important
for dance music plucking everything destroys
the dance ability it makes it sound clumsy
whereas the slurs make it sound light even
the most famous classical guitarists like
Andres Segovia have actually famously ignored
these historical tablatures in the sense that
they didn't know what the markings on the page
all meant or they simply chose to ignore them
and it's a byproduct of not understanding or
ignoring the historical tablature you don't
get this danceable Baroque piece instead you
get something that sounds like this [Music]
[Music] now while I'm not of course saying
this sounds bad because Segovia was a great
musician an artist it's clear that if he
was to pay more attention to the historical
tablature and the notation he would arrived
at something completely different [Music]
foreign [Music] now in case this is sounding
overwhelming wow how are we supposed to know
what all these symbols mean well let me help
you out in the same manuscript where you'd find
that minuet by Visée at the very beginning
in French he describes how to play all the
symbols he writes so he writes when I write this
little comma on this note I want you to play
a trill, a tremblement, when I write this note
with a little X I want you to play martellement
which is like a mordent if I write a DOT below a
note I want you to play it with the index finger
of your right hand that's one dot two dots
is your middle finger so it's giving us all
sorts of information about right and left hand
fingerings ornamentation symbols it's all there
in the manuscripts speaking of the dots under
notes for the right hand fingering this is one of
the most important things to know about historical
tablature in the Renaissance if you look at almost
any Renaissance Lute book of which there are many
you'll see that very often under every other note
there'll be a DOT meaning to pluck with the
index finger of the right hand so when you
have long scales like at the end of Lachrimae
Pavannee or flow my Tears by John dowland
A DOT under each note means to play with index
and usually you play the other note with the
thumb that means we have this alternation
between the thumb and the Index P and I in
classical guitar terminology and because the
thumb is a big heavy digit which goes down
with gravity and the index is a weaker
digit which Goes Up Against Gravity we
get strong weak strong weak strong weak and
the Renaissance they call these good and bad
notes this is musicians beyond the grave
from 400 years ago telling us what they
considered good taste they thought it was bad
taste to play to play Everything strong they
thought it was a good taste to play strongly
strongly strong week so bad taste would be
and good taste with the fingers
prescribed in the manuscript [Music]
regardless of whether or not you'd actually
like to play on period instruments you can play
directly from the source from the manuscript and
you can learn so much about performance practice
and the composer's intent from doing so not
only that these manuscripts are beautiful
to look at and there's more music out there
just from 1400 to 1600 then you can play in
a lifetime I'll put some links in the description
to some big books of manuscripts that you can all
play through and even you guitarists who are
playing classical steel string electric guitar
you can play directly from these manuscripts
too take your guitar which of course is tuned
e-a-d-g-b-e and the third string G is going to
drop down to F sharp you can do this by playing
the open B string and then the fifth fret on
the third string and then make them sound the
same. [Music]There. Now it's a lute. You can
play directly from the manuscripts like a lute
[Music]
so I really hope this video helped you understand
historical tablature and convinced some of you
guitarists to start taking a look at it and even
learn to play from it if you enjoyed today's video
make sure you subscribe and hit the Bell so you
don't miss other videos I post like this one if
you want to help me make more videos like this you
can go to my patreon and there you'll find lots
of behind the scenes content about what I'm up to
the videos I'm making performances I'm giving and
you'll receive rewards like early viewing on all
my videos my CDs and you can even get a private
lesson with me and lastly if you're interested in
learning classical guitar especially at your own
pace at home I have a beginner online classical
guitar course called Classical Guitar Pro it's
six hours long 53 videos so I hope you'll check
that out until next time thanks for watching.